Mes 3 minutes n'ont pas déjà commencé, n'est-ce-pas ?
Chris Anderson : Non, vous ne pouvez pas faire démarrer les 3 minutes.
Remettez le chronomètre à 3 minutes, ce n'est pas juste.
Allison Hunt : Oh mon dieu, c'est rigoureux ici.
Je veux dire, je suis déjà assez nerveuse comme ça.
Heureusement, je ne suis pas aussi nerveuse qu'il y a 5 semaines.
Il y a 5 semaines, j'ai subi une chirurgie de remplacement total de la hanche
-- connaissez-vous cette opération ?
Scie électrique, perçeuse, totalement dégoûtant.
Sauf si vous êtes David Bolinsky, pour qui ce n'est que vérité et beauté.
Bien sûr, David, si ce n'est pas ta hanche, c'est vérité et beauté.
En tout cas, j'ai une anecdote révélatrice à propos de tout cela,
donc Chris m'a invité pour vous en parler.
Mais, tout d'abord, vous devez savoir 2 choses à mon propos.
Juste 2 choses.
Je suis Canadienne et je suis la plus jeune d'une fratrie de 7.
De plus, au Canada, nous avons un formidable système de santé.
Ce qui signifie qu'on a des hanches neuves gratuitement.
Et étant la plus jeune des 7,
je n'ai jamais été en première ligne pour quoi que ce soit. Compris ?
Donc ma hanche me faisait mal depuis des années.
J'ai finalement été allée voir un docteur, ce qui est gratuit,
et elle m'a dirigé vers un chirurgien orthopédique, aussi gratuit.
Au final, je l'ai vu après 10 mois d'attente -- presque un an.
C'est ce que vous donne la gratuité.
J'ai rencontré le chirurgien et il m'a fait des rayons X gratuits,
et j'ai pu les analyser et vous savez,
même moi, je savais.que ma hanche était à remplacer.
Pourtant, je travaille dans le marketing.
Il m'a dit : "Allison, nous devons vous faire passer sur le billard.
Je vais devoir vous remplacer la hanche -- Il faut compter 18 mois d'attente.
18 mois encore.
J'ai déjà attendu 10 mois et je vais devoir attendre 18 mois supplémentaires.
Vous savez, c'est un temps d'attente tellement long que je me suis
mise à penser en terme de conférences de TED.
Je n'aurais pas ma nouvelle hanche pour ce TED.
Je n'aurais pas ma nouvelle hanche pour TEDGlobal en Afrique.
Je n'aurais pas ma nouvelle hanche pour TED2008.
J'aurais toujours ma vieille hanche. C'était tellement décourageant.
Alors, j'ai quitté son bureau et j'étais en train de marcher dans l'hôpital,
et là j'ai eu ma révélation.
Cette benjamine de 7 devait elle-même prendre la tête de la queue.
Oh oui.
Puis-je vous dire à quel point c'est non-Canadien ?
Nous ne pensons pas ainsi.
Nous ne parlons pas de ça -- hé -- on ne l'imagine même pas.
En fait, quand nous voyageons à l'étranger, c'est comme ça qu'on retrouve nos compatriotes canadiens.
"Après vous." "Oh, non, non. Après vous."
Euh, êtes-vous du Canada ?" "Eh, moi aussi ! Salut !"
"Formidable ! Excellent !"
Donc, non, soudain je n'étais plus contre le fait de sortir le premier vieux venu de cette liste.
Un homme de 70 ans qui voudrait une nouvelle hanche,
pour qu'il puisse retourner au golf ou s'occuper de son jardin.
Non, non. En tête de la file.
Alors, je marchais dans l'entrée et bien sûr, ça fait mal,
à cause de ma hanche et j'attendais un signe nécesaire.
Et j'ai vu ce signe.
Au travers de la fenêtre de la petite boutique de souvenirs de l'hôpital, il y avait un signe
qui disait : "Besoin de volontaires." Hmm.
Ils ont bien voulu m'inscrire aussitôt.
Pas de vérification de références, aucune analyse de parcours, non.
Ils cherchaient désespérément des volontaires
car la moyenne d'âge des volontaires à l'hôpital est de 75 ans.
Oui. Ils avaient besoin de sang jeune.
Ainsi, aussitôt, j'avais ma veste bleu vif de volontaire.
J'avais mon badge et formé parfaitement par mon chef de 89 ans.
Je travaillais seule.
Tous les vendredi matins, j'étais à la boutique de souvenirs.
Alors que je vendais au personnel de l'hôpital des Tic Tac,
on me demandais de temps en temps : "Que faites-vous ?"
Et je leur disais : "Bien, je me fais remplacer ma hanche -- dans 18 mois.
Ce sera formidable quand la douleur sera partie. Youpi !"
Tout le personnel connaissait la jeune et boiteuse volontaire.
Mon prochain rendez-vous avec le chirurgien était par hasard
juste après un de mes tours à la boutique de souvenirs.
Donc, naturellement, j'ai ma veste et mon badge.
Je les ai posés en faisant bien attention sur la chaise dans le bureau du docteur.
Et vous savez, quand il est entré,
je pouvais vous dire qu'il les avait vus.
Quelques temps plus tard, j'ai une date d'opération pour dans quelques semaines
et une grosse ordonnance pour du Percocet (NDT oxycodone, médicament anti-douleur.).
Au fait, la rumeur veut que ce soit en réalité
mon volontariat qui m'a permis de passer devant.
Et vous savez, je n'ai même pas honte de ça.
Pour deux raisons.
Tout d'abord, je vais prendre tellement soin de ma nouvelle hanche.
Mais surtout, je pense continuer le volontariat,
qui m'a permis de réaliser quelque chose de bien plus grand.
Même si un Canadien gruge le système,
la société en retire un bénéfice.